today is May 9
Europe day and that means that in less than 1 month
on June 6
we are going to vote for the european elections
now the EU voting guide was released yesterday
so let's take a look
to 1 pair of those statements
and what different parties think of it
I am not going to discuss all 30 of them in this video
but let's look at 1 pair
which the parties disagreed very much about
the first for which 9 parties once voted and 9
parties have voted disagree
is about LGBT plus parents
because there are some countries
as in Italy who have passed laws
what makes it
that with quer parents
not both parents are often recognized
as the real parents of the child
and this statement says now
the EU must prevent this with rules
to prevent this
these are the parties who agree
companies have to pay more for their co
2 emissions
quite a lot of parties agree with this
but not these more judges
1 very relevant
actuelle proposition is about cooperation with Israel
De Stelling says this collaboration
between you and Israel must stop
until the palestinian people have their own state
a lot of parties disagreed with this
the parties that agreed
party of the animal sp and the pirate party
and 3 more parties had voted for it
neither
and that is the training
bvda d 66 and volt
have to put 1 hour more money into it
the network of european trains
thus better infrastructure
and also that it gets easier so that people
less likely to catch the plane
quite a few parties agreed
except these 4 judges
migration is 1 very large
subject in these elections
as were in the national elections
this statement says
that people who
aziel applications must do that outside the EU
and there too have to wait and see if they
get aziel
a lot of parties agree
especially so uh the more judges
but also,
for example, the sp
and then we see more center
left-wing parties and the SGP
we say we disagree
the right to abortion must become 1 European right
1 European fundamental right
instead of being through the countries
itself is determined
there are 1 pair of parties who agree
and the rest don't think this is a good idea
I would definitely recommend using the full voting guide
to do yourself
you can do it at your point voting guide point NL
and I would also recommend that you not only take 1 test
but also take a look at
what the parties have to say
what is in the party program
so that you can make6-6-1 right choice
in the european elections